hello everyone and welcome to my channel
today we have breaking news it sounds
like III 2020 has been cancelled this is
a both a bigger deal than you would
think in a much smaller deal than you
would think so everyone you know off to
GGC got cancelled South by Southwest got
cancelled both conventions I was
supposed to be at
I even had a convention in Orlando get
canceled I was supposed to be doing so
much traveling March and it's all gone
think I'm mostly happy about it actually
there were speculations that III would
be cancelled basically because of the
virus the potential pandemic that is
coming our way it is considered to be
unsafe to have large quantities of
people within the same space and III
though it calls itself the largest video
game convention in the world and is
actually not games comments you know
does have a number of attendees may not
have Xbox may not have PlayStation may
not have Activision they all already
pulled out and EA still lodge convention
draws a lot of traffic to downtown Owen
so people have been wondering about this
for a while but people who are actually
in contact with the ESA journalists who
do not include myself trust me if the
contacts that I had at the ESA was still
talking to me I would have asked since I
was pretty brutally unkind to them after
they doxed my phone number and email
address both of which have been changed
I feel so sorry for whoever like has
inherited that phone number what a
nightmare they will not talk to me about
anything which I guess is what happens
in these situations but AHS Technica
specifically has posted III as we know
it is over multiple sources familiar
with the Entertainment Software
Association or ESA s plans have
confirmed to AHS Technica that the
organization which is responsible for
the annual Electronic Entertainment Expo
will soon cancel the three-day Expo from
what I'm hearing from friends in the
industry it's going to be canceled
tomorrow morning so for a lot of you by
the time you watch this video we might
have already woken up to a tweet or a
press release from the ESA saying it's
going to be canceled I have also heard
that that is not true it's just that
they are considering cancellation and
actively talking about it but there is
no
pending announcement I guess we'll find
out tomorrow but technically the first
ones to like whistle blow this which is
a real real ball of a bowler of a move
there is a devolve a digital to
publisher they said cancel your III
flights and hotels y'all they thought at
this
I think everyone kind of had whispers
that this was going to happen and then
devolve a like wed of alpha what going
for it if you haven't heard of devolve
a-- just go watch one of their e3 press
conferences and you'll get a very good
understanding of who devolver digital
are as a company they're wonderful but
back to I was Technica it says one
source who spoke two hours on background
said they'd heard the news of e3 2020s
cancellation directly from esa members
and that an official public statement on
the matter was supposed to be today
Tuesday March 10 and slipped
representatives to the ESA did not
immediately respond to us Technica's
questions about the state of e3 going
forward all whether the events seismic
shift may instead mean a delay a move to
a completely different venue or a wholly
virtualized live-streaming event a delay
would make a lot more sense to me
cancelling III seems like a very strange
choice because here's here's a thing
that you know it's gonna sound obvious
to some of you but I feel like it is not
generally in the public conscience is
that III is not the press conferences
the Microsoft press conference the
Nintendo directs the PlayStation press
conferences in the past
Ubisoft ea Square Enix sometimes PC
those are not actually a part of e3 when
you work III it starts usually Friday
now in was Saturday for a while I was
covering that as a journalist for almost
a decade that those those press
conferences are not owned or paid for by
the ESA all of those companies who
booked venues to do those things could
absolutely still do them the ESA Part
III is actually just the show floor days
at the Convention Center in downtown LA
which I think is Tuesday to Friday
Wednesday to Friday one of those days is
a half-day as well like it's not it's
not the full week so this isn't the
press conference is being cancelled
because the ESA can't cancel anyone
elses press conference they have them in
their own venues they run on their own
schedules they function at their own
time
you know that they're completely
independent I feel like those companies
probably will cancel any life Oh in
posting press conferences because they
also want to avoid the public safety
concerns of having everyone in the room
together while there's a potential
pandemic it's not a good look for anyone
but yes back to the article okay exactly
why the event will be canceled it's not
clear at this time again I'm ashamed
that it's because of the Chimera virus
late last month the ESA address concerns
about the spread of corona virus and its
impact on major 2020 Expos around the
world by insisting that it continued to
plan for a safe and successful III while
otherwise monitoring and evaluating its
potential impact on events held in Los
Angeles which seems like the responsible
thing to do honestly following that
announcement III contracted creative
directors the merchandise and events
company I am 8bit resigned from its post
after five weeks on the job that news
followed a February announcement a long
time Etha III collaborator Jeff Keeley
would not be participating in this
year's Expo what I heard about Keeley
which I did not hear from Jeff himself
so I want to absolutely present this as
like just something I heard that's it
but what he did for e3 was run the
Coliseum YouTube live is a separate
thing that Jeff does like being on
YouTube like I think the last like four
years in a row
that's YouTube live at e3 and that is
again alongside the press conferences a
separate thing Jeff was the host of the
e3 Coliseum and I have hosted panels at
the Coliseum I did three last year and
the rooms never full anyway so you know
that that was a very cool opportunity to
see someone do dev interviews in the
same way that IGN Watto GameSpot would
on the show floor as part of the
official III programming where the
schedule would tell you go watch this
panel as part of this convention it's in
the same area you can do that a person
not a lot of people did that but what
I've heard is that III upon shifting a
lot of their strategy this year just
based on sales in general and also a lot
of the publishers pulling out of e3
because I guess it's not that beneficial
to them anymore you could just do things
remotely Nintendo's proven that time and
time again is that to drive more traffic
to the Coliseum which again was not a
high trafficking thing from what I
perceive having worked there they wanted
to have Jeff or whatever other hosts
interview a lot more streamers
youtubers influences sometimes even like
sports players like celebrities rather
than actual Deb's that's not what Keeley
does for a living if I were him and I
would told that by the ESA I would
probably also not want to do that that's
not really the spirit of III naturally
that is I'm trying to get the mass
market to approach the show and I get
why they're trying to do that I actually
don't think it's you know distasteful of
them to be approaching it that way but
if that is why Keeley pulled out I get
it but yeah as this mentions yeah I
officially ditched III and 2016 operate
EA play a standalone event timed
alongside III on an annual basis ever
since you could do that at any time of
year any time you could do a PSX I you
could do any of the Xbox events that
they have globally any time of year we
know that for the big publishers III no
longer existing doesn't really matter
aside from the loss of press because you
have to remember III was a trade show
initially my first year it was a trade
show it was not open to the public it
was for media for devs to get their
games in front of media for them to plan
the marketing cycle to get previews to
have interviews a lot of that stuff was
embargoed it was basically just like a
press cycle for media to talk about the
video games that they saw at e3 the
press conferences are a little more
complicated because III press
conferences in some cases are actually
for stockholders they expect those press
conferences every year this is
definitely going to affect the stock
market not having any press conferences
this year for the companies that have a
history of having them could result in
their shareholders you know being like
well you don't have that hype this year
we wait for this every June you don't
have the excitement we can't rely on the
hype of your games because we're not
seeing it in action because of there's
no e3 so that could legitimately affect
stocks which affect company practices of
course if your stocks go down you
probably announce another mobile game
try to get that money back
but yes the big publishers are not
majorly affected people who are majorly
affected funhouse funhouse is a biggest
week of the years III IGN biggest week
of the year z3 by a dramatic margin both
of those companies make a lot of money
in that week all the media outlets are
going to suffer by not having the
traffic that comes with the millions of
people visiting gaming websites during
the e3 the same applies to YouTube it's
usually come with video games funhouse
is kind of an example there there is
this week that everyone spends months
and months planning for that is now just
gone so this is going to affect these
businesses in I think pretty significant
ways especially if long-term this leads
the bigger publishers to being like we
didn't have to do it there in person we
can hold our and press conferences
wherever we want and we're going to do
that the one thing I think they all lose
out on by not holding their press
conferences in the same week is the
amount of fans who aren't necessarily
even interested in any Xbox products are
even interested in any Nintendo products
or Ubisoft products who watch all of
those press conferences for the
spectacle that is III for the
competition for the hype surrounding the
whole event I think once they splinter
off it's less beneficial to everyone but
in terms of actual video games I think
the people who are hurt the most got a
the marketing teams who've been planning
everything they've been doing around
preview builds or you know releases at
e3 who have to just completely
reconfigure their entire annual budget
that's got to be a nightmare and also
the Indies who debut their games on
stage I think for them that's a really
big deal III is a chance for a tiny game
from a studio you've never heard of to
again be in front of millions of people
and without that hype of e3 there's
almost no way for a indie darling to
just show up and steal everyone's hearts
again look I personally am bummed about
this because like yeah I'm not happy
with the ESA for leaking my details it
did try to sell a class-action lawsuit
against them but I was a lot more
complicated than you would think
we tried but I love III it's one of my
favorite weeks of the year I love it
I'm so exhausted running on pure
adrenaline that whole time doing the
live shows and being on the show floor
and getting to play games there for the
first time and talk to devs he was so
excited to show things off another
really special part is like meeting a
lot of independent journalists who are
trying to break into the industry III is
one of the only times of year that they
can meet the people that they need to
get in contact with same applies to
Deb's who go to GDC who aren't able to
go this year
you know these conventions provide huge
assets to those people and I have no
doubt that GDC will be coming back next
year it's III that's the big question
mark but the in-person stuff probably
isn't going to go away it's just it's
significant so the cultural significance
of it that will be gone but you know
when I was like 12 years old I was
waking up at 4:00 a.m. in the morning to
watch the press conferences live in
Australia not having any of those would
be a huge bummer
I always said because a lot of the
industry a lot of my friends are really
Kromah Jenny about e3 a lot about the
journalists or other people who work in
publishing on whatever else is very much
like oh three oh I'm so sick of it I
always said that the minute that I
stopped loving III and stop being really
excited for III is when I need to leave
the industry because why would you want
to be an industry in an industry that
doesn't excite you if you have the
option not to be right if you could do
something else
but I never stopped losing the magic for
me never I love it again do you want to
reiterate because I imagine people will
jump to conclusions here I guess we'll
find out this does not mean any of the
press conferences it canceled because
they aren't technically a part of III
anyway it was always just something that
made sense to you around the trade show
side of things because journalists were
in town to be in the room to do it but
that is obviously not a focus for them
anymore they're more fan focused now
anyway I would guess they will be
cancelled not because III was cancelled
but because they don't want to put
people in a room during this period of
time and my guess for e3 is that it will
be delayed but yeah when most people
watch this video again in the morning
that news will probably already be out
well maybe this is some other later time
this week I guess we'll see good luck
out there wash your hands bye everyone